welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host he mazus and on this week's episode
I was joined by Phoebe stal forbs who is
the founder of a accountancy and finance
recruitment business based in Lancashire
called dot recruit in this episode we
really sort of dug deep into what that
business Journey has been like over the
last three years where she started the
business just before Co so she had to
navigate that and how she's been on a
journey on uncovering what type of
business it is that she wants to build
how she's being able to really double
down on service and how they've become
the number one accountancy Finance
recruiter in the local area and so much
more I love Phoebe's passion her energy
and I'm really excited to see where she
takes her recruitment business over the
coming years
enjoy Phoebe welcome to the podcast
thank you so excited yeah no thank you
so much for uh making the trip yeah
haven't had too many Northerners yet on
on the Pod here you had any female
Northerners yet yeah you had Amy
actually you yeah yeah so um look where
we would like to start um is sort of
just to to get your thoughts on like
what you believe are the characteristics
traits uh that you find a common in sort
of modern day recruiters High performers
like what is it that you think make up
today sort of highest performing
recruiter do you think you know I feel
as though this is something that I've
put a lot of thought into as I'm
recruiting for my team and I don't know
if there's any like one magic formula
people might disagree but I think the
one thing I've noticed time and time
again that seems to translate to a
really good recruiter is you know when
you get someone that is driven by more
than just Billings you know they're kind
of like they've got that higher purpose
they they they want to achieve something
they want to be the best they want it if
you know what I mean they want they want
it enough and I don't know whether like
I think of all the highest billers that
I've ever worked with they were driven
by something and whether they tapped
into what that was I think it helps to
know um but whether they tapped into it
or not it was what got them picking up
the phone every day it's what got them
in early got them staying late and I
know like in myself when I've had
periods of time where I've got other
things going on usually that I've needed
a bit more money for like I'm buying a
house or doing it up or whatever that's
always helped me just get my head down
and just crack on like I really wanted
it in that moment yeah I like that and
have you have you sort of figured out
how you uh uncover that and then into
envir think it's tough because I think
it's always changing like depending on
what you've got going on in your life
usually if you've got like a big
milestone that you're working towards
you might be a little bit more motivated
when you've got something in particular
you're working towards but sometimes you
haven't got anything in particular that
you're working towards and and what I'm
trying to figure out is how you know
where where is there that consistency
you know these people that really get
their head down regardless of what
they've going on they've got going on
and they're just consistent day and day
out and I think that's what contributes
overall it's those baby steps every
single day isn't it and then you look at
the year and you've absolutely smashed
it so um I do think a lot of it does
come down to drive and motivation and
work ethic and wanting it really so
obviously I was saying earlier obviously
these conversations go really quick so
I'm really Keen to really yeah get into
the detail of the last three years
obviously for the last three years
you've been building your own
recruitment business recruit but I guess
let let's just yeah spend um a couple of
M moments just talking a bit before that
obviously before you started your own
business how many years was it that you
worked at another agency seven and a
half I think for one Agency for one
agency yeah climb the ranks yeah a lot
changed over that time actually so I got
to see I want to say I got to see a few
different businesses even though it was
just one because when I started it was
quite a very small Niche Boutique agency
and then they became part of a PLC part
of a wider group and the dynamic of the
business changed over time so I was
quite lucky got exposed to different
things yeah so I guess what what I
always like to hear from people and I
know other people like to hear it as
well like how who was who was Phoebe
before
recruitment H so I got into recruitment
when I was 199 so if I cast my mind back
to who I was maybe when I was at
school I wasn't really
sort of exceptional at anything I was
pretty average at everything do you know
what I mean so like sports academically
I was just bang on average I didn't
really have I hadn't really found my
thing so when I got into recruitment at
19 I I fell into it really because I
didn't want to go to UNI and there was a
lot of pressure to go to UNI from
grandparents and things and I thought I
I can't do it I don't know what I want
to do so I got into Recruitment and kind
of finally realized that that's my thing
like I can control how good I am at this
and you don't you don't really have to
be particularly talented there's certain
personality traits that help obviously
but I think that was the first time in
my life that I was like wow I'm actually
really good at this and I can be really
good at this and it's all within my
control it's it's not purely based on
Talent it's such a moment that is a lot
of people can go out their entire life
looking for that yeah and cuz I for me I
yeah I had an idea and then I found
myself in a sales role and then I was
like oh my God like yeah like you just
said I can get paid for the hard work
that I put in and I I control that yeah
so it's interesting you say that ju Just
quickly because I think this would be
helpful People for People a lot of
people listen this podcast who are young
um maybe graduated from uni maybe
considering going advice for people that
are having to deal with their parents'
pressure of like Phoebe go to UNI it's
going to make us look good we want to be
able to tell people that our child is
going to Oxford like that's a real thing
that a lot of people have to sort of
deal with and with yeah how did you how
did you deal with that and advice for
others a do you know it was so tough
because a little bit of background to it
my granddad was pretty much like rags to
Rich's story like he was an orphan grew
up in an orphanage and worked at from
the age of seven on Preston fish market
and grafted so that he could provide for
his family so I was very fortunate that
he picked out a really good school for
me and my sister and and for two of my
cousins
and so the pressure was on to make
something of yourself because he'd
sacrificed so much to get us in that
position and it was really them that out
of the four of us myself and my cousins
it kind of became apparent that if
anyone's going to go tuni it's going to
be me so I was a bit like oh how do
I say or how do I prove that not going
is going to be the right thing so that's
probably what drove me in the early days
but I think all I can say to anybody in
that position is I personally don't
regret not going to UNI actually I think
it was the best thing I could have done
I look at um when I'm paying my team and
I'm looking at the student loan on the
pay slips and I'm like oh gosh I'm so
glad I don't have to pay that back um
but yeah I think if you know what you
want to do absolutely stick by it and
hopefully your parents will trust that
you'll have it all figured out how how
family relationships been like sometimes
they can be right yeah I mean they
they're very proud of where I am now and
my granddad um you know he was in sales
his entire life you have to be when
you've got your own business businesses
and you know he's proud especially now
now that he's seen that I've you know
it's been 10 years later now that I'm
actually three years into my business
and I can tell but I mean he he's a sort
that always wants to push you so he
doesn't want to give you too much credit
for it so um but no it paid off and I
think anybody that I speak to in the
same situation has said the same like
they didn't go and if anything that gave
them something to prove and that's what
was the driving force behind them doing
really well thanks for sharing that so
so let's so let's talk about the these
three years then right so do recruit is
your own recruitment business yeah I
guess let let's just start with what was
it that you believed you could and
wanted to do differently from obviously
those that that that amount of time that
is with the other business yeah a lot of
people when they think about going out
on their own sometimes a Big Driver uh
besides yeah being Their Own Boss
wanting to make money for themselves
rather than the company is like I really
believe that I can do this better I
really believe I can yeah do things
differently what what was that for you
so it was never really about the money
um I think it was for me it was more
about as the business that I worked for
grew I started to see that there was
more of a an emphasis on quantity over
quality and it was all about the money
for the business and I'd spent a long
time building my relationship ships and
I didn't the more I climbed the ladder
the more I realized it was really tough
to meet these really really high targets
and preserve these relationships i'
spent such a long time building and I
wasn't prepared for anything to
sacrifice those relationships CU that
was what was most important to me um so
I think the vision with Dr crew I never
planned to grow the business actually I
was I was leaving to be a bit of a one
woman band a bit of a freelancer just
working with the clients I already had
and I think it's really just just it was
all about the relationships and being
that trusted go-to person and as you
know I work a really niche market really
small local market so it was all about
the reputation and providing a great
service really for me and and like what
what from your perspective how was it
that you was going to deliver on that
was it just like doing the right thing
yeah like actually getting back likeed
you know I mean what were some of the
cool things that you think if I do this
all the time or I commit to this or I
definitely do this in my business then I
would achieve that cuz I think a lot of
people say that but like what what does
that actually mean is different to
people I think anyone that knows me is
sick of hearing me say do the right
thing cuz that's actually one of our
values and we didn't realize that until
kind of coming up to the end of year two
I've never been a lover of company
values I've always thought there were
just a bit just pick three buzzword and
we'll say there are values but I kind of
realized that we had the team had
something in common and we all
absolutely live and breathe the same
kind of mindset around our clients and
one of them is just do the right Thing
by people and I'm a big believer that
everything else just falls into place
and follows if you just focus on I mean
spend your time wisely obviously but do
the right thing and ultimately
everything else pays off love that so as
well I think recruitment is very
competitive I think just for context
when uh you're saying there that you
work in a local niche market so like for
you that's accountancy and finance yeah
in Lancashire in Lan yeah that's tin
that's the focus
so talk to me about uh I'm I'm still I'm
assuming here that that market is still
competitive yeah it is so like how how
did you go about thinking I think you've
done a really good job on on The
Branding front thank you but like I
think that's another sort of key bit
that a lot of people are concerned about
when going out on their own is like how
am I going to how am I going to stand
out there's so many different
recruitment companies going be so
competitive like how did you think about
what was the plan and strategy around
how am I going to make do also look and
feel different um and actually has a USP
in the market which is for most people
very competitive yeah so I think
everything came down to just posting
regularly on LinkedIn and just being
authentic and and just I think me and
you had a chat once and did a little bit
of a session on what to post and I think
it was just you're getting a little bit
of a role with it and all of a sudden I
noticed that I was getting quite a bit
of decent engagement and I felt like
there was quite a lot of people rooting
for me as well like people that I knew
clients and candidates just really kind
of rooting for me and that spurred me on
and actually looking back I did a post
the other day on the best three
decisions that I made in that first year
and one of them was investing time in
building a personal brand because within
six months that was already paying off
and I think it was in the way that I've
been doing I've been making a BD call
and when I introduce myself they go oh
yeah I've seen you on LinkedIn and I've
be like wow this is massive door opener
and some of them it was hilarious there
some of them that were like a little bit
St I bet you get that a lot actually
some of them were they were a little bit
like oh the famous Phoebe St ringing me
and I'm like great like it's just as
simple as getting your name seen on
LinkedIn and it opens all these doors
and part of me was kicking myself
because I thought seven years I've been
on LinkedIn as an observer not doing
anything where would I be if I have
started this seven years ago so massive
sort of anybody that asks sort of what
should I be doing I would just say get
on LinkedIn and just post don't worry to
too much about it just post and have you
found then that building your own brand
has directly impact impacted recruit
absolutely yeah so there was a good
period of time I would still say this
now but we have had a little bit more of
a push recently on BD because we we're
after certain type of client but for a
good time we didn't have to do any BD
because everything was inbound um and it
was a combination of uh the link in um
sort of presence and um reviews on
Google so because we're in such a a
local
space I just ask every single candidate
and client that we work with would you
just write us a review an honest review
about how you found the service and
within 12 months we were the highest
rated accounts and finance recruiter in
Lancashire on Google um that's what you
want to be if you're just focusing on
Lage yeah exactly and that was one of
the things that I don't like blowing my
own trumpet at all so I think when you
can say like you know have a look at us
on Google and all of a sudden we're like
there with our 6 five star reviews and
I'm like there you go like it or people
would type in accountancy recruiter
Lancashire and because we because of all
the reviews we' be straight to the top
so that helps no that's brilliant so
let's talk about this first year yeah
how difficult was it I think a lot of
people can advertise and make uh this
recruitment entrepreneurial Journey look
very sexy and sort of outside looking in
you just see the pictures on LinkedIn
when they had their record quarter and
when they're hiring people but for you
and your experience we're three years in
that looking back at that first year I
think cor if I'm wrong when we were
preparing for this at the end of that
year like you said you didn't initially
plan to grow it but there was like two
of you I think was it yeah so um we set
up in July 2019 just before Co so we had
nine months before the pandemic hit yeah
so I'm obviously we know that the
pandemic if you're in your first year of
business that really really wasn't ideal
so obviously that was challenging but
let's not talk about that so that that
nine months in in the kind of run up to
the pandemic um the most difficult thing
honestly that I would say was the
isolation of I was literally just
working at my kitchen
table I'm a socialable person I have to
be around people I can't be alone with
my own brain for too long because before
I know it I'm overthinking why my garden
has not turned up today and I'm like
what like what's wrong with me so for my
motivation and I realized quite early on
I always thought I'd be this one woman
band but quite early on I'm thinking I
need I need staff I need a team I need
people around me or I need to go and
work with other people CU I can't be on
my own all day it's no it's no fun it's
boring um so that's what Mo that's what
really I found tough and I met Sofia so
sfia was my first member of staff and I
met her when the business was only four
months old but I wanted to make sure
that I had at least six months of her
salary R in the bank so that if anything
did happen I you know I'd give her time
to get up and run she didn't have any
experience I didn't know how well I
would bring somebody on um so I said to
her look as soon as I've got this amount
of money in the bank we're good to the
job's yours she was working for the for
a local college so she was in this dead
stable job and then obviously we'd said
April would be a good time for it to
start and then obviously she hands
noticing the day after we're going to
lockdown and I rang going I was like H
about that notice
H Reon you can like retract it and just
kind of like stay because I was just
thinking the risk we all my jobs had
literally just been cancelled and I'm
like oh you don't know how things were
going to play out honestly it was like
bonkers the T the way the timings were
she handed a noce in the next day the
country's locked down so she was I
honestly don't
know what it was that made her stick
with it because we've been having these
conversations since the October before
she started the following July wow so
but she was just determined she really
wanted to be a part of it so yeah by the
by the end of the first year we got our
first office and I got my first employee
and it was there that I was like right
this is where the fun stuff happens now
not on my own anymore so let's just talk
about that cuz I I've definitely
experienced that I think a lot of people
can relate to this so like when you say
it was really Challen like that was one
of the biggest challenge
like how how did you deal with that did
you I don't know always end up speaking
to your part part like do you have
friends that you could speak to like how
did you find ways to socialize or I
don't know what what was actually
Difficult about that cuz I think
sometimes people can underestimate that
um and I think yeah can take for granted
that they're part of the the team and
that's one of the funnest Parts about
recruitment yeah and I think one of the
hardest things that I found is
definitely like I don't know if you
found this is like yeah like I don't
know you achieve a goal whatever and you
just find giving yourself a high five
it's just not as fun really yeah did you
deal with that I know you said like I've
recognized that so I wanted to hire but
like how did you actually what helped
you deal with that cuz you still carried
on with that yeah uh
so I would say for me the key was just
getting variety I I liked to have a
change of scenery from time to time and
not just be sat on my own in my kitchen
so I'd go and work from a coffee shop
where even though I wasn't talking to
people there was a little bit of like a
buzz around me and I could just see
other stuff happening um I inquired a
few co-working spaces actually and
didn't even get there before Co hit so
that would have been an option and I
think I would have quite enjoyed that
and then I had other friends that worked
remotely in the jobs that they did so
one of my friends was like an online
travel agent so one day a week we'd work
together that's nice but what I started
to find was we had to really try and
make sure we weren't distracting each
other because we both worked in quite
isolating jobs and when we were together
we'd just chat so we'd have to then
really hold ourselves each other
accountable so yeah
another common challenge out here I
don't know how you found with this and
may not be just specific to the first
year and the entire Journey so far I
think a lot of people can be very um
what's the word not fearful but when
people think about setting up on their
own they're very conscious that they
don't know all the business stuff
accounting HR all that like how DA has
that been daunting for you have you
navigated that has that been more
challenging than you expected because I
think that can that also holds a lot of
people back yeah
so you really need to make connections
with people that know what they're doing
basically and I think if you've got
people to reach out to like anybody in
your network probably ask you like who
would you recommend to help me get all
my terms of business in place and you
probably know someone that would know
someone if you know it's it's all about
having your network I think of people
that are experts the only thing I really
know how to do is recruit and so what I
needed was sort of the back office
functions in place to be able just to
recruit and from day one was it yeah so
I actually worked with um I don't know
what you'd call it like a if you call it
like an incubation company but it was
actually a business that supports
recruitment startups um and to be honest
if I had have known that I was going to
grow the business and be a lot bigger
whether I would have gone down that
route I'm not too sure I probably it's
great if you're going to just be a one
person band because they can just raise
all your invoices for you do all your
accounts do all your legal stuff it
stuff your website everything and that
was great um but the way that it is
structured is you pay them sort of per
invoice that you raise you will pay them
like a small percentage forever for like
a certain period of time I didn't I this
yeah yeah so um so we set this up for
like a three-year contract which is I
mean it's still working quite well and
it's still at the moment cost effective
because I absolutely milk it for like I
will send
and they know that and they they joke
about that how I do love to get my
money's worth but actually the way that
I look at it is that's cheaper for me to
do that than it would be to hire an IT
person An accounts person a HR person
all the rest of it and it's also the
time you would spend on it thinking
about it worrying about it that you
don't have to yeah so what so people
yeah like would you recommend people to
consider going down that route not the
particular company that you work with
but I guess that is also something a lot
of people consider
they are wary of it they don't have
those expertise and that might stress
them out so it sounds like yeah you
Outsource that basically yeah and there
are a few other companies that do that
as well um the one that I there's been
particular challenges with the one that
I have worked with because 12 months
after I signed up with them they were
taken over and the service changed
changed H so that's been a quite a big
challenge for me because then I was tied
into them so all I would say is maybe
grab two or three companies that do this
thing and find businesses that work with
them and are contracted to them if you
will like I have with mine and ask them
call them and just ask them firstand how
have you found it what's the what's good
what's not so good and just weigh it up
um you can some people do that some
people don't like the thought of being
tied in so there might even be ways that
you can tie in for less amount of time
but it was I got a really good deal with
them to be fair um so I was pretty happy
with that but everyone's different and
then what about just keeping on the
topic of challenges I guess obviously
second year was like Co Vibes yeah right
so let's talk about obviously recently
not too long AG had your third year
anniversary right so let's just let's
just keep it um to the last year like
what what have been maybe some of the
challenges that you've been most
surprised by didn't expect uh in the
last year cuz now you got a few more
people in the business how many people
are you today uh so including myself
we're a team of five yeah five exactly
so yeah the last year what have been cuz
I'm sure now but going into that third
year you've got a bit of a flavor of
things to expect the highs and lows what
what was yeah some of the challenges
that maybe you least expected this year
um do you know what overall I wouldn't
say this I'm really lucky right now and
I can say that there's not been a huge
amount of real challenges year one was
the hardest and then since then it's
flown really nicely and but if I was to
really think about what's been most
difficult I think we've had a couple
we've made a couple of
potential I don't want to call them a
hiring mistake but we didn't quite know
what we were looking for when we first
hired so we did we wanted an
administrator we brought somebody on on
the government Kickstart scheme and it
wasn't quite the right fit for our
business and it wasn't actually what we
needed in the end and which was we only
brought them in on a contract so it was
all okay and I was just glad that it
wasn't permanent and then we tried to
bring another person in to do a bit of
like re like resourcing and admin and
absolutely loved she felt recruitment
wasn't for her but to be honest I would
have been I would have been moving her
into a consultant role because I don't
think we actually needed that so I think
the challenge for us has been figuring
out what do we need as a business and
trying really hard not to follow the
typical what I've always experienced
when I work for my old company was every
team of sort of five six Consultants had
an administrator actually don't need
that and I think that's what's been
quite difficult when you bringing staff
in and it's their lives and it's your
business and the teams imped you've got
to get it right and that's quite
difficult really hey everyone a real
quick one from me this podcast would not
be possible without our amazing podcast
Partners Vin cherry and Source Breer
because you listen to this podcast
you're able to get your hands on
exclusive savings on both of these
award-winning products if you're a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out Vin Cherry who are an
all-in-one operating system for your
growing recruitment business with Source
breaker if you want to make sure that
all of your recruiters have the best
best tools on the market to stand out
and beat their competition then you have
to check out Source Breer use the link
in the show notes in the comments below
and you'll be able to get yourself
exclusive savings on these amazing
products yeah it's funny right this
always tends to be the most common
challenge like yeah hiring for your own
company yeah I went for dinner with
someone recently who yeah is like yeah
18 months into their own recruitment
business journey and he sort of said to
me that the things that he thought would
be the hardest like win a new business
standing out all that he's found easier
and then the things that he would think
he'd find easier been the hardest light
Hing for his own team getting people
bought in like have you found how have
you how have you found like uh the
people that you've hired or hiring
people uh and I don't know you feeling I
don't know if you've had this like like
obviously it's your business so like
you're even more motivated yeah have you
had to navigate that or like feel like
you've um hard people had to understand
that these people aren't going to work
as hard as you well do you know what's
really interesting I I don't this is
going to sound ridiculous I don't see it
as my business really yeah I see it as
our business okay because so there's
five of us at the minute for a long time
there was four and we we just had a
quarter of it was a quarter of the
business each and we were directly
responsible for our little quarter of
the business and that's very much how my
team see it um I don't and I'm quite
transparent with my team I don't pay
myself more than my team the money in
the bank isn't my money it's to be
reinvested and that's how I've always
seen it and I think because of that they
the people that I've got are probably
quite motivated by that rather than if
it was right you're working for me and
this is my vision and my dream and I'm
going to take all the money out or I'm
going to go and set myself up for a nice
little life and leave you all working
here and that wouldn't work for us like
it it's you know and everyone's
different and everyone's motivated
differently but I know that my team are
motivated by they feel like they are a
part of something and they are a part of
something and it's ours for the Tak in
if you will the market is ours so yeah
quite lucky with that really well you
think you've been able to make people
feel have have you just been lent into
being transparent and honest with
everyone and people you found people
bought into that yeah absolutely like I
was laughing because my accountant rang
me in at the end of the financial year
and said you do know that you've got
quite a lot of money here that you could
take you know when you get get to the
next tax threshold so you can take this
much as a a dividend if you want to take
it and I was like wow I looked at what
I'd paid myself for the year I'd paid
myself like 21 Grand and I was like cool
like that's like nice I don't don't need
any more than that to be honest I live
quite a simple life and but I just
thought that's so funny like my team
have made an absolute Fortune between
them obviously commission and stuff and
I'm just here like bumbling Along on 21
Grand a year but I think um I've always
been pretty open with them about that
and I intend to carry on being quite
open and I was quite inspired in in the
early days I went went to I used to go
to whatever free thing I could go to
just to be around people and there was
this women in business event going on
and there was this lady there called
Sandy Lindsay who has um a marketing um
Company in Manchester and she was
talking about how she put the company
into employee ownership and it really
kind of sparked something for me and I
thought that is great like imagine
joining a company and knowing you own a
piece of it so my team know that
longterm plan that's on the cards if we
can get it to work so so do you think
looking back then I've sort of found
this sitting down with um people like
yourself or people that have been on
different Journeys like when you said
you started the journey you felt like it
was yeah maybe just going to be on
yourself one person business do you
think like for people considering uh
going on that recruitment
entrepreneurial Journey that it's it's
important to really understand what type
of business that they want um I don't
think it is really I think you can just
kind of in a way go with the flow with
it I that's what I did anyway because
and I think the reason I did that was
because I didn't want to set the
expectation early on that I'm going to
have this massive business and massive
team because what was important to me
was doing the right thing and if
somebody doesn't share that vision and
that value then we're not growing the
team and it is as simple as that and if
it just remains just me because I can't
find those people then that's fine so I
don't think you necessarily need to know
how big you want to scale it it's great
if you do because like go hell for
leather at it but if you don't know I
think that's okay as well just to let it
organically end up do you think it would
have helped you though make decision do
you think it would help you make
decisions if you knew from day one that
you wanted an employee own company you
wanted to be certain amount of people I
don't know I think that cuz think a lot
of people can get caught up in like
different should I be doing this should
I be doing that and often times it comes
from a place of like like not not
knowing like what
you're going obviously you can only for
me I do really struggle when people are
where you see the business in 5 years
for me I really struggle with that so
it's why do you struggle huh because
because I just think anything can happen
basically so I just feel like I can
write down what I want it to be but I
don't know I just feel like so many
things can influence that so for me yeah
so I guess I'm asking that cuz I speak
to a lot of people who yeah can find
themselves in a difficult position and
they're like you can then almost find
yourself like should I hire someone
should I be doing this
and often times it's because they
haven't really thought about like where
they want to be in another 12 24 months
time or the type of company they want to
own yeah I've noticed that every time I
have a plan something else happens
that's not that plan but turns out to be
better so that's been your experience
that's been my own experience so I feel
like I can't comment on what other
people should do with that but if that
you know you might find the same happens
and at least have a a rough kind of plan
of where you want to go but
also kind of in a in a way and this does
not feel right for a recruiter but kind
of let let go of control of it a little
bit and trust that as long as you're
working hard and you you know you're
doing the right thing good stuff's going
to come from that women in business yeah
women in recruitment yeah do you think
you've been disadvantaged no because
you've been a woman in recruitment no so
obviously we had a brief chat about this
didn't we and
and um you mentioned about a podcast
that you'd listen to which I then
happened to come across and listen to
about um I suppose people deci I think
you can jump on the bandwagon of oh as a
woman in business it's harder for me def
recruitment I think part of the
narrative and I don't know whether
sometimes it can depend on H what Market
you're recruiting into if you like for
example my sister runs a business in the
motor trade so she gets mansplained on
is it mansplained on the daily
I don't know what that means so
basically a man will explain something
to you that you know about oh right okay
man you know you know full well what it
is but they will explain it like you
don't so CU my sister works with she
sells Ali wheels so on a daily basis she
sells alloy wheels yeah okay um so on a
daily basis she will get that kind of
conversation you know and that
patronizing sort of approach from a lot
of people and she finds that really
frustrating and actually she holds her
own and she knows stuff so you know
that's great for her so maybe in the
industry that you're in if it is you
know did you have to navigate that while
she was building your career not at all
I I will never I mean we once had um we
once had a managing director as the
business group we became part of this
group we once had a managing director
who was the most sexist pig yeah and but
he was just he was just a dick do you
know what I mean he was just one on his
own and he was like that with everybody
and it wasn't wasn't because I was in
recruitment it was just because that was
him so I wouldn't I wouldn't say I've
I've really come across any challenges
um at all maybe maybe I'm just sort of
ignorant to it and great that's the case
but may maybe I've been lucky I don't
know but I wouldn't personally say that
being a woman has got in the way um of
anything we've talked although we have
talked about how you know the one of the
dial I think a lot of women face when so
I'm 29 so I think one of the dilemmas or
upcoming dilemmas is going to be what do
you do about having a family um so I
think if there was going to be anything
standing out about women in recruitment
it might be that um and when I've seen
people I've worked with you know go off
and and have kids and then come back to
work they've always felt this guilt
around are they doing recruitment well
enough and are they doing motherhood
well enough and how
it's very hard to balance that and how
are you going to balance it um so I
think one of the one of the things that
drives me and always has has been
um Freedom basically and working in
recruitment really is is my ticket to
freedom and one of the things about
having my own business is that I can be
as flexible as I need to be because I
don't have to report to anybody and I
want my team to feel the same that
whatever flexibility you need it's yours
um so the way that I I've got a great
team to be fair and one of the things we
talk about in every single oneto one is
the succession plan and I've given
myself three years to get the business
to a point where I can leave it for a
bit you know for 12 months and go and
have a child and then come back to it
you know potentially part-time because I
don't the way I look at the business is
there are people better probably better
than me within my
business stronger billers than me and
probably better people managers than me
in my business so I'm not that fuss
about keeping a really tight hold on
that because they'll probably do a
better job to be fair so that's how I
will B I will balance it um hopefully
how do you think you would have balanced
it if you stayed employed would you be
more concerned yeah I would the business
I was working for yeah I would
because there's no way I it's hard to do
it recruitment job part-time it's really
hard it's not part-time job you end up
trying to fit a full-time job in four
days and that that's how it is and I've
seen that and I've seen how draining
that is so I personally would have
struggled with that um and maybe I would
have moved out of recruitment maybe I
would have gone to see if I could sell
some alloy wheels with my sister instead
cuz yeah I have I have like that's been
the Insight that I've taken from the
conversations that I've had but I I I
would like to think that it's evolved
more cuz I think I've I've interviewed
um women who almost feel like they've
been like hard by when coming back like
just it's been made more difficult like
because the perception is like you just
said can they do the job parttime so
should we just get someone that isn't
going to be working part-time to work
their patch take their clients all those
things you know I've got one of my team
on Matt Le at the moment Sophia
and it's one of if anyone can do a
full-time job parttime it is like she
is like incredible but I don't want her
to feel that pressure so she will be
supported in whatever way she needs
support and she knows that like we'll
we'll have a chat about whatever
flexibility she needs and whatever
support she needs from me on her desk
like she will get if she needs to bring
in a resour so that's fine like we'll
we'll figure out I think more and more
companies will um have that mindset I
hope so so talk to me about like in
terms of people listen to this a
subsection of people will be in insired
or one day uh really like the idea of
having a own recruitment business sort
of knowing what you know now what what
would you sort of um what advice would
you offer to these people that you think
would um put them in the best position
to have the start that they they really
want to have yeah okay what what comes
up for you on that so A few things if
they're if they're just starting out in
Recruitment and they know that one day
they want to work for themselves the
best thing they can do right now is
focus on their reputation in every
single conversation that you have if you
just do the right thing by people you're
going to just as a byproduct build that
fantastic reputation and that's going to
be super helpful when you go to set up
on your own I've seen a few people try
and set up on their own without that
reputation to fall back on and that's
when it's risky really and there's
always an element of risk when you set
up on your own but you want to try and
eliminate that risk wherever you can and
that's one of the areas you can if you
um if you are sort of like couple of
years into recruitment I would say once
you get into like a senior consultant
role from that point I'd say you'd
really want a couple of years in a
senior role to get as much experience as
you can and as much much exposure as you
can to how that business runs um how to
lead people coach people support people
just try and just be a sponge and learn
it all and start at that point saving up
basically so one of the things that
was I I don't know if we would still be
here if I hadn't have done this because
obviously the pandemic hit nine months
in and there's always going to be the
economy to contend with always um but I
started saving money uh to cover six
months worth of my wage you gave
yourself a six Monon Runway yeah and as
it happened I stretched it out to 12
months I just scrimped for 12 months but
without that I bought myself time there
to do it right and not to feel that
pressure to immediately bail and make
the wrong decisions like everyone in
recruitment will know that if you're if
you're entering a month and you've got
your target to hit and you've not really
you know had any kind of like forward
orders and you're going into a month on
zero the pressure that you are then
under doesn't actually help anything
doesn't usually equal the results
usually when you um I suppose think
ahead and you're always a month ahead it
flows nicer and it's the same when you
set up on your own you need time to get
it right and just to build your clients
and do the right thing so get your
savings get your money in the bank and
don't see the money in the business as
your personal you might have a really
you might get a nice 10 grand fee and
think right I'll leave five grand in the
business and I'll take five grand out to
treat
myself that's risky again because you
don't know what next month's going to
look like so just give yourself as long
as you can and as much time as possible
I like that so yeah early on yeah just
build just put everything into your
reputation yeah definitely agree with
with that I think that's a great insight
and then yeah definitely I think if
you're a senior or in the leadership
position yeah really lean into yeah
getting exposure to pnls and how
different things work terms of business
and yeah really get there's so much
experience that you can get from that
yeah and then yeah I guess sometimes it
can be overlooked just be a bit smart I
feel like some people can almost find
themselves like I'm done with this like
I just I need out and then yeah they've
got a lot more pressure on their back
maybe than that was necessary yeah um I
guess before before we finish then and I
sort of get your thoughts on um where
this business is going what we really
excited about I guess I I feel like I
may know the answer to this but I want
to ask it because I think often times
when I speak to people one of the the
biggest concerns uh they have when
starting out is definitely um how
quickly am I going to be able to sign
turns with my first client do deals uh a
lot of people have to contem with
covenants for 6 months 12 months um what
what has been like the the most
effective way for you to consistently
win business and and get that first deal
done what I don't know what ended up
really working for you quickly do you
think uh so I was really lucky I only
had a four month uh restri yeah they I
think it was a typo on my contract they
cocked up big time um so I was like so
buzzing for that so I saw that as a as a
four month opportunity I knew after four
months all my existing clients that I'd
worked with for the last seven years
will be on the phone so I had a four
Monon window there to BD around
businesses I've never worked with before
so when I was with my previous employer
I had quite a small patch so I had half
of laner basically so for that four
months I focused on the other half of
Lancer that I'd never been able to touch
before and telling them a little bit
just around my story as to why I've set
up and people want to help they want to
support yeah so it was just really nice
to do that and that paid off because
four months in all my old C I rang them
straight away I was like I can work with
you now and they were buzzing i' book
visits go visits visits is the big one
just get out there get in front of them
you'll always win business but I'd
booked visits with all my original
clients and it it wasn't a problem it
was just getting in front of people it
just works every time it's just the do
the basics I think it's interesting
right because I think you might almost
think that being a small little business
people may I don't know not buy into
that or you think oh I've been part of
this established business so that's why
this but again when I was catching up
with my friend he was saying actually
it's it's been quite the thing that I've
really found is that com actually really
resonate with our story and what we're
doing so you you found that and do you
know what as well I've asked my clients
for feedback on if you were to compare
our service to the likes of the big
players in the market how does it
compare and they say well you haven't
got a big name to hide behind your
service is you're exposed and it's all
about your service and if you lose a
client that's your business gone you
know not just one you've got to get it
right whereas when you've got a big name
to hide behind then doesn't really
matter if you screw people over on along
the way that business isn't going to go
bust so that's one thing that my clients
have noticed you're exposed and you you
can't hide I think you can you can fall
fall into the Trap can't you of like
trying to overplay what you are before
you're there yeah because you can be
quite self-conscious of how you're going
to be perceived it's just fee on our
kitchen dining room table doing this
going to take me seriously
but actually if you really own that and
demonstrate that look this is going to
mean a lot to me it's going to mean even
more to me and then you deliver on that
it's actually something that people
really buy into and actually yeah like
like doing business with yeah absolutely
so where where's this business going
then obviously three years second year
had to deal with content with the with
Co you're no longer alone yeah right you
got a team that you seem super proud of
and happy with yeah so where where's
this business going over the next couple
years then so this is the first we're
just about to head into our four fourth
year and this is the first time where
we've gone into a new year where we've
got a team that know what they're doing
they don't need any don't really need
any more training we have an ongoing
training session every Wednesday morning
which just fills in the blanks um really
but the team are all just set up now
just to go and Smash It and the plan
really what we want is I mean me and you
have talked about having that million
pound company and I think it is just
that that vision of that's when you know
you've got a really good business but I
want to try and do that with as few like
the fewest kind of recruitment
Consultants I can I want everybody to
just to be absolutely maximizing their
potential and to be really well
supported and down the line to have a
piece of the pie and to then kind of
leave it up to the team as to what do
you want to do with the business do you
want to grow the business so you're
happy with the size that it is where
where do you want to go with it I'm not
fussed I'll just come along for the ride
I'm quite happy I love that yeah so what
you're most excited by
um just continuing to enjoy the journey
I just I'm really enjoying it like I
love going to work so I can't say I just
want to keep seeing where it goes and
just excited about the future in general
yeah well I'm excited to look outside in
where it goes I sort I've always enjoyed
our conversations and I think um yeah
kudos to you like in terms of being
being smart with your money at the
beginning didn't know Co was around the
corner um and it seems like you've
really grown um into leading a team
running a business and it sounds really
exciting so thank you so much coming on
the podcast enjoy and really excited for
everyone to listen yeah Fab thank you